my dad was a deadbeat dad but he was a  doctor specialty  abortion  i still made it so i guess you're not  good at your job got you  people were judging me it's like why you  need a couple therapists you're only  three months in oh just one little  reason i'm in an interracial  relationship during a pandemic race war  that's all you know  i'm heterosexual but it's against my  will  another dude i dated was giving me a  back massage she's like yeah i went  kickboxing earlier today and uh four or  five dudes i'm not even sure if i could  take you  take me where  to an nfl scrimmage or we know you want  to see me run a 40. what's going on  right now  i'm on peacock  [Applause]  [Music]  you